in this video we'll talk about the
phases of T cell mediated immune
response if we plot the immune response
in y-axis and time in x axis then we can
visualize the events of T Cell responses
in real time so if the first phase is
activation phase where the T cells
interact with antigen presenting cells
and get activated
the second phase is clonal expansion the
third phase is effective response phase
and then eventually the number of T cell
would decline so there is a decline
phase and lastly memory T cells might be
generated so it's like a memory phase so
all these five phases would be discussed
in this video step by step so stay tuned
till the end
so the first step is activation phase
dendritic cell or any other antigen
presenting cell would recognize a
pathogen-associated molecular pattern or
pamp using the toll-like receptor
present on their surface after
recognizing this they would display
these antigen on Class 2 MHC molecule
and migrate towards the lymph node and
now the dendritic cell is in the lymph
node in the lymph node it would interact
with naive T cells with the help of TCR
and CD4 co-receptor
this interaction give rise to the signal
1 for T Cell Activation B cell expresses
a molecule known as cd80 and cd86 and T
Cell expresses cd28 this specific
interaction give rise to the signal 2
for activation
and the third signal for Activation
comes from the cytokines
in context of T helper cells il2 is the
key cytokine that give rise to the
signal 3. all these three signals lead
to the activation of T cell
what happens when the T cell is
activated generally the knives T cells
are resting in the g0 state they are
quiescent
after activation they would re-enter the
cell cycle and proliferate rapidly this
is known as clonal expansion it is
important to note that out of many
different type of T helper cell or cd8
positive CD4 positive T helper cells
only the cell which is specific for this
antigen would clonally expand not all of
them only a selective population would
get expanded this is known as clonal
expansion
and chloral expansion of lymphocyte is a
Hallmark for vertebrate adaptive immune
responses
now there would be an effector phase
where the T cells would interact with B
cells so this is the CD4 T helper cells
eventually they would activate B cell
into plasma cell and plasma cell would
secrete antibody to show the responses
so they coordinate with B cells also
they can secrete cytokines which can
attract many other cells including apcs
neutrophils and many immune cells on the
other spectrum of the effective response
there is cd8 positive T help T cells
which are cytotoxic T cells which
secrete cytotoxic granule and kill the
cells in the second half we would talk
about the cytotoxic granule and the
effective response for cd8 positive
cells now let's get back to the CD4
positive cells silipor 4 positive T
helper cells are generally helper cells
so they secrete Messengers that can
trigger other cells and they can do many
job indirectly
so there are many subtypes of these T
helper cells and each of these subtype
secretes different type of
cytokines such as cth1 positive subtype
secretes interferon gamma and tnf
th2 secretes interleukin 4 5 and
interleukin-13 which are important for
dedicated functions
the regulatory cell secretes
anti-inflammatory cytokine like
interleukin 10 and TGF beta th17
secretes pro-inflammatory cytokines such
as il-17a 17A final 22. so all these
cytokines has their own immune
modulatory effects
now another important job of T helper
cell is to activate the B cell
T Cell interacts with the B cell with
specific T cell receptors and there is a
interaction of cd40 and cd40 ligand
which leads to the b-cell activation
activated B cell would proliferate
rapidly and expand clonally activated B
cell in the lymph node would undergo
processes like Affinity maturation which
selects the high Affinity antibodies on
the B cell surface also they would
undergo a process known as class
switching or isotype switching which
would produce a specific type of
antibody and from the plasma cells So
eventually the activated B cell would
differentiate into the antibody
secreting plasma cells
now we are coming back to the cytotoxic
cd8 positive T Cell responses imagine
this yellow cell is now affected by the
virus so once the virus has entered the
cell
some amount of the viral peptide would
be also displayed on the class 1 MHC
molecules and this class 1 MHC molecule
bound peptides can be recognized by the
cd8 positive cytotoxic T cells
immediately these cells know there is
something wrong so they have to act
promptly they secrete several cytotoxic
granules which has perforin and
granzymes these particular cytotoxic
granules get into the cells so perforin
and granzyme lead to activation of
apoptotic pathway granzyme activates
bead on the mitochondrial membrane which
allow the leakage of cytochrome c one
cytochrome C is leaked in the cytoplasm
it can interact with a puff one
eventually leading to the activation or
cleavage of inactive caspase 3.
3 is active and can execute the process
of apoptosis there could be also fast L
and fast mediated uh
apoptotic pathway
which lead to the activation of
caspase-8 and eventually the executor
caspase class Space 3 is activated
as a result of these caspase activation
death of the virus infected cell is
caused and the nearby cells are saved
from the viral infection this is how our
cd8 positive T Cell work and this is the
effector mechanism
B8 beat CD4 positive or cd8 positive T
Cell after the job is done of pathogen
so when the pathogen elimination job is
done
so many cells doesn't need to be there
so there has to be eliminated and immune
system selectively eliminate them via
apoptosis
so there are few cells which are
remaining these cells would eventually
become the memory T cells when there is
a second time of infection these cells
would promptly act in the second round
of infection
now it's also important to understand
the antigen exposure kinetics determine
the response kinetics
so here the T Cell response kinetics is
in red and blue denotes the antigen
exposure kinetics
so here is the T Cell response kinetics
where you have a naive T Cell which
would be activated
and it would ultimately become T
effector cell
and eventually when the pathogen is
eliminated antigen level is down then it
would become a memory T cell
this is the normal scenario but in many
cases T cells get exhausted when they
encounter pathogen for a very long time
or antigen for a very long time they get
exhausted they become unresponsive
towards stimulation and this is known as
a state which is characterized by
specific molecular markers this is very
important in context of cancer cd8
positive T cells fight the tumor cells
and they eventually kill the tumor cells
but once they are exposed to tumor
antigens for very long time because
tumor cells are dividing at a very rapid
Pace then the cd8 positive T cells
cannot cope off they eventually becomes
very exhausted
and go to a state of unresponsiveness
they are characterized by expression of
several molecules it's a hyper
functional state
and the efficiency of these cells are
dramatically compromised at this kind of
scenario there are two options either
fight till the last breath and die or
the second option is
Phi tiller end but now become
unresponsive
so basically option b is selected by
many cells
because they get tired they get
unresponsive but it's a reversible State
eventually with proper time and proper
stimulation it can be reversed
but these are the new findings these
days in T cell research I hope this
video was useful and we can appreciate
the T Cell response kinetics if you need
more notes and flashcards quickly visit
our Facebook page or Instagram you can
support us using super thanks you can
pay via PayPal paytm and UPI see you in
next video